prend la direction de blue avec cette
légèreté cette gaieté communicative que
l'on retrouvait aujourd'hui entre les
restaurants et cinémas aurélie renault a
capté ce moment trinquer en terrasse
ces étudiants attendait ce moment avec
grande impatience
on comptait venir ce soir mais on a eu
des cours d'aduler du course existe est
l'occasion de venir malgré le temps la
pluie le vent la grêle c'est pas grave
dans tous les cas on comptait me dire
c'est la reprise on attend ça depuis
plusieurs mois eh ben ça fait plaisir ça
fait du bien elle est comment cette
petite bière à les succulentes vraiment
bien au déjeuner les blésois se retrouve
entre amis ou entre collègues fini
désormais les repas pris en solitaire
sur le coin d'un bureau ne peut ne pas
être seul face à son petit tupperware
face à son sandwich et elle retrouver la
convivialité tout simplement de discuter
face à une assiette à un plat de chaud
dans ce café restaurant du centre ville
toute l'équipe a retrouvé la clientèle
avec plaisir dès ce matin un vrai regain
de motivation
tout le monde est content les clients
les serveurs les cuisiniers on trouve
enfin un but pour se lever le matin donc
ça fait plaisir à tout simplement
moi je me mets à la place des pilotes on
a besoin de ça 2 de refaire le monde
de la terrasse d'un café bien sûr c'est
notre boulot c'est la base dans les rues
piétonnes la vie reprend vêtements
chaussures bijoux
les boutiques sont ouvertes les clients
retrouvent avec plaisir les conseils
avisés des vendeurs tout le monde est
heureux tout le monde se dit bonjour
sourire jusqu'aux oreilles
les clients sont rendez vous donc après
un mois et demi de fermeture
heureux de reprendre clap d'ouverture
également pour le cinéma les lobbys à 14
heures pour la toute première séance
depuis des mois une quarantaine de
spectateurs redécouvre le plaisir des
salles obscures pour la semaine à venir
les réservations s'enchaînent on a nos
habitués retraité vit en a certains qui
ont pris quelques
que place 4,5 pour la semaine qui ont
pris les devants donc on est content est
vrai que ce matin on a eu pas mal de
coups de fil d'habitués ou non qui se
demandaient qu est ce qu il faut
réserver en avance une jauge de 35% dans
les salles 50% sur les terrasses les
établissements devront attendre le 9
juin pour accueillir les clients sur des
jauges plus importante